what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with kang uh only myself left
to conquer right we are at the
conclusion here and i'm sorry it took so
long just been doing a lot of traveling
and whatnot and it was hard to kind of
make this make a make a good video about
this right but now i am back home and we
are back on our regular schedule so uh
in this video and this what's really
cool here about this conclusion is that
this is what really
solidifies king and and i would say
removes him from being just kind of like
this ambiguous conqueror that exists out
there in the multiverse somewhere that
like does things from time to time and
actually brings them more down to earth
because in reality that's kind of what
king needed that over the years in
marvel comics kang has just kind of been
this guy who exists in the future
sometimes he shows up he fights the
avengers every once in a while you get
like what is it the original avengers
forever and the time keepers and
immortus and all that kind of stuff in
the destiny force but you never really
got to see a story that focused so
heavily on why kang is the way he is and
what this one does is it really changes
that so the idea here is that following
what was basically the death of ravana
ren slayer right the one woman he's ever
loved more than any other that kang's
desire to conquer was less about just
like creating some massive empire for
himself right in the last video we
talked about how he did that but it left
him feeling empty it didn't fill that
hole that he thought it would fill
because the reality is that hole was
reserved for ravana rinslayer but
without her in the picture he just
wasn't really able to do the kind of
things he wanted to do and that's what
was so cool is because he didn't feel
complete when it comes to this idea of
love and this is one of the things that
i want to specify here right when it
comes to the idea of love i think it's
very easy to take a cynical approach
right love is the only socially
acceptable version of masochism right
like we go out into the world and we
intentionally harm ourselves over and
over and over again in the hopes that it
won't actually hurt this time and we'll
find the person we love more than any
other it's very easy to become cynical
in that way when it comes to the notion
of love and for fair reason right i mean
there are people who've been hurt so
consistently that they just by default
associate love with pain because that's
the only thing love has ever caused them
is pain but the reality here is that
depending on who you talk to some people
will say it's worth it and what kang is
doing here this is one of the things to
know the establishment of chronopolis
was not built as some place for kane to
basically rule his empire from some
distant point in the future across the
entirety of the multiverse instead it
was to basically find his love and so
when he establishes chronopolis one of
the things to know and the easiest way
to understand this is that it's like
this empire right this citadel that he
has that has strings across the
multiverse he is almost like uh like
thor in the bifrost right that like you
have asgard and you have the bifrost
bridge that allows thor to access any of
the dimensions that are tied to the
bifrost chronopolis allows uh king to
access any of the universes that he's
conquered and even some of the ones that
he hasn't right it allows him to
basically travel back and forth
throughout the entirety of the time
stream and the multiverse it's just kind
of his base of operations it was also
the base of operations for immortus as
well but the thing about this is is why
it was built was because of the fact
that what he wanted to do was create a
place whereby he could essentially
scatter the entirety of ravana
rinslayer's atoms across the time stream
now i know it sounds kind of crazy in
doing that but he literally says i call
this place chronopolis he says this is
where we will live ravana and he says
where you'll live i swear it even if it
takes a thousand attempts she was not
you but she had wisdom go my ravana and
be infinitely reborn in the space
between the stars so the idea behind
behind kang here is to basically scatter
her entire existence across the
multiverse and she'll be reborn in every
single universe that exists across the
multiverse at that point it's him just
trying to find things now what he says
here is so intriguing he says in those
moments of mastery for i had become the
master of time i often thought that
epochs and eras were measurements for
lesser men that had not invented the
chronology that could contain kang i
brought the chronopolis the greatest
monks of the buddha and the most
enlightened shia warrior priests and
through their teachings and on rare
occasions over their corpses i came to
an understanding a master does not allow
his love to die those are the actions of
a boy a master compels that which he
controls to become that which he loves
using every bit of chronopolis's power i
unraveled the very fabric of time i
found the threads of fate and made the
city its loom and from it i wove a
machine of constant replication i
injected ravana rinslayer's very soul
into time like a die into the threads of
an entire tapestry where time had taken
her from me i forced time to do the
opposite the birth of an infinite number
of ravanas in infinite timelines giving
myself infinite chances to save her the
plan was genius it was flawless until it
began and what we end up finding out
here and this is one of the interesting
things that kang really is it's almost
as though kang has this mastery of time
but he's also a slave to it because
every single reality that he goes to no
matter what he does she always dies that
in one reality she dies from the plague
in another reality she actually rejects
him right and it takes him by surprise
but no matter what he does and no matter
how hard he tries he always loses ravana
renslayer there's nothing he can do to
have her no matter what the circumstance
is there's no way to get her and after
all these countless attempts after all
these efforts what it's done is has
turned him cold and that's one of the
things to know here and that's one of
the things to see is that while we don't
necessarily know the exact origin of the
original kang at the beginning of the
story that went back and visited
nathanael who became this version of
kang that we're seeing now all we know
is that their origins seem very very
closely intertwined that the causation
behind what made them who they are is
still the exact same thing that when he
finally finds a version of ravana rinse
slayer that he's that he comes to
believe may love him the reality is she
rejects him and it's not due to anything
regarding his character or at least his
physical form and so far that she finds
it unattractive or anything like that
she rejects him because of his character
and what he'd done to her and what she
really states here is she says the great
machine knows time it sees all those who
manipulated plus i could smell you
across the time stream you hideous
jackal and she says my life you made me
believe you were a good man and then you
stole my life and where kang says no i
saved you ravana you saved me and i
loved you i love you so i saved you the
response here is she says my life was
not yours to save my life was my life
right i died presumably when i was
supposed to or by whatever manner or
whatever means but what you've done is
you've taken my life away from me right
you have taken away my ability to
actually live a life that was meant for
me instead every life i've ever lived
across the entirety of this multiverse
has all been engineered by you every
single life has been designed like
intricately by you not in so far as
exactly how her life unfolded but
basically she was created for a purpose
and the purpose was to satisfy the
desire of kang to have someone in his
life imagine if that were the case but
imagine if tomorrow somebody showed up
to you to visit you and said hey the
whole reason you exist is because i
created you and i created you for the
express purpose of being my lover
suddenly your life has no meaning your
life has no value because the life you
lived was never truly your own and
that's what she experiences here that's
what really torments her here and so
where kang realizes she's kind of a
failure that ultimately kang says okay
fine another failure there's nothing i
can do here he goes to attack her and
basically destroy her and in the process
of this she destroys chronopolis right
she says you're the wound in the time
stream king like you fail to realize
even after all of this you're the
problem and that's one of the things
that the king says here right he says
that all that's left to do here is to
cauterize the wound and he says i do not
remember these moments well right
because just his whole manipulation with
time screws with his memory and he says
i think i did not want to remember the
screams and he says and of course time
was collapsing the end of my rescue
operation was much closer than i'd
imagined so the mind
as the final act of this ravana rinse
layer before she's destroyed she
annihilates the entirety of the
chronopolis and so he says the ashes of
chronopolis are there if you look for
them no matter what your temporal
position a bit of dirt on your mantel a
penny from a distant year a book that
you swore to read that chronopolis just
as its very function and operation
literally exploded throughout the time
stream with its atoms and bits and
pieces just kind of skewed everywhere
and what he says is that in its
destruction kang unlike you and i who
would just kind of be blown back maybe
100 feet or 50 feet or 500 feet or
whatever it is kang was blown through
the time stream and so he literally fell
through time and so it's one of those
things because as he was falling he says
i arrived 10 minutes early and then
ultimately he arrived to see his younger
self and he says i was younger than i'd
remembered nathaniel richards eyes i
remembered once as my own i had felt so
powerful so capable i'd looked at kang
with disdain the sneer was insufferable
i swore to erase it from the boy i gave
him the chance i'd been given by the
monster who made me but with the benefit
of my knowledge i would give him the
trauma i would do it right right i would
correct the mistakes of of essentially
my father right i would correct the
mistakes of the kang that came to me
that visited me when i was younger and
brought me through the time stream
what's so beautiful about this story is
it's the relation between a father and a
son now it's not exactly a father and a
son but by all standards of measurement
you could argue that it is right kang's
parents when he was a child were already
dead he was basically raised without any
real parents at all so when kang from
the future came back to visit his
younger self took him under his wing
into the time stream he very much became
a father figure but what he was was a
father figure that was traumatized by
his own experiences his own abuses his
own personal torment and as a result of
that much like a lot of parents out
there he passed that on to his child and
so it's really an answer to the question
what happens when a child is raised by a
parent that never learns the real
lessons of their own experiences and
that they try to impart on their
children the better parts of themselves
but in their failure to learn their
lessons they ultimately impart on them
the worst parts of themselves that at
the end of the day the story of kang is
cyclical it's always a circumstance
where kang always becomes king but
notice this it's not king showing up
here and saying i will teach you to
become a conqueror so that you may
enslave all of existence no he says i
remember the wood under my fingers the
betrayer tears that left unbiden into my
eyes did his mouth taste of bile did i
lay bleeding did he shiver and sweat and
he says did he feel the noose tightened
around his throat an inescapable moment
a broken heart hate fury so hot it will
burn the stars and so ultimately that's
what happens right he says what had been
was again the lesson he needed the one
that in my fury i felt forced to teach a
lesson and so ultimately it's exactly
the same thing that no matter what
happened no matter how things unfolded
kang can never have ravana red slayer he
will never have that woman in his life
he is always destined to lose that which
he loved the most and like any rational
human being out there in the face of
losing what they love the most he felt
anger and instead of accepting the fact
that that's just the way things unfolded
for him he basically took that anger and
that rage and passed it on to his
younger self and what he thought was
basically the right lesson to teach
never love and so literally this cycle
of abuse just continues that while the
lessons may have been a little bit
different or how he taught his younger
self may have been a little bit
different at the end of the day the root
cause was the exact same and so that's
how kang always becomes king that he
says one last chance to save ravana i
had been given one last chance and i
done only what time demanded i was no
master i was a boy it made me hate him
all the more that she knew me even from
the start as i danced with addie she
knew she knew me for what i am but all i
wanted to be was more than nathaniel
richards and so in the end what he was
trying to do was basically make
nathaniel the opposite of him he was
trying to make nathaniel a person that
wouldn't become him but the lesson that
nathaniel learned just like the lesson
this version of nathaniel learned when
he was visited by the king before him
was that that version of kang was a bad
guy that he would seek to destroy him
all the while failing to realize he
would become him and that's what he says
right he says that like that younger
version of nathaniel left in the night
stealing the only time armor that he
thought kang owned and kang even says
run nathaniel run and become you think
me conquered but it was not kang who has
died this day for nathaniel richards is
not a boy nor a man nor a hero nor a
villain he is only a beginning and he
says a kang and a tyrant a villain and a
hero we will be all things experience
all things the beginning and ending of
time and hours by immortality's boon you
will have the power of a god and when
you have lived in immortal's life still
here you will stand never love and he
says how could i when there is no one
left to love across all of time my
ravanas are gone my past affixed its
loop completed her grip upon my heart
releases and so the husk stops i have
found my desiccation and he says let
armageddon be a funeral pyre for there
is but one escape from eternity's trap
and i stand upon its precipice i need
not even junk i need merely to finally
rest alexander wept because he could not
conquer himself but i am not alexander
and literally that world that he's in
right when that meteor strikes he's
there at the very moment and simply
leaves right just leaves on his own
vessel and he says rest in fire
nathaniel richards rest knowing you have
bested all you thought to be great in
this world die knowing you stand astride
destiny give your face and voice to he
who created and who in turn created you
and above all things though all on time
and space may conspire to defeat you
never ever
love that's the irony of this that's the
irony and the beauty of this whole story
that when kang when when this version of
kang was visited by the king before him
that that king said never love all it's
going to do is bring you pain and
suffering and sadness and the response
of nathaniel was that's because you
didn't know love all you knew was
conquering love's the greatest feeling
in existence it's the greatest thing of
all and that at the end of the day this
that that younger nathaniel went on his
quest to find a way to defeat that king
to destroy that king to show that
version of kang that love truly is
powerful but when he encounters it what
that younger nathaniel failed to realize
is the power of love is so extreme that
it can break a person on the most
fundamental level and i'm not talking
about those those guys out there who
really liked the girl in their science
class and they don't like them back and
so love is bad no no i'm talking about
the people who gave their life to
someone right i'm talking about those
men and women out there right who live
the life with somebody else who spent
years together right brushing their
teeth next to each other for 30 years
and truly understand the meaning of
sacrifice right and that significant
other just changed their mind one day
and left or they were hit by a car and
they died whatever the case is that that
person became that person's other half
right like they had spent so much time
together that they were intertwined in a
way that can scarcely be defined and
when that person either left or or or
was taken from them that that person had
become half their heart and half their
mind and half their soul and how do you
live without that right and so to truly
understand what it means to love and
then to have that taken away and to not
only have it taken away to know you can
never get it back it can break a person
on the most basic and fundamental level
and that's what younger nathaniel never
accounted for that's what he never
considered is what that what what it
really meant to love and then what it
meant to never be able to have that love
that's what broke him and so that's the
the interesting lesson here is at the
end of the day kane the conqueror
despite all of his vaunted power and
despite all the things he says and all
the things he does and the grand
campaigns and all that kind of stuff
kang is nothing more than a guy who
exists out there in time and has
experienced a broken heart an infinite
number of times but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end let me know you guys think down in
the comment section i absolutely love
this story probably the single greatest
story that's ever been told about kang
and i will catch you all later
peace